- أهلاً بكم مرة أخرى في سلسلة فهم المعلومات والحوسبة الكمية.
اسمي John Watrous وأنا المدير التقني
للتعليم في IBM Quantum.
هذا هو الدرس السابع من السلسلة وفي هذا الدرس سنناقش مسألة تقدير الطور وكيف يمكننا حلها
باستخدام حاسوب كمي.
ثم سنطبق تقدير الطور على مسألة تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة إلى عوامل، التي ناقشناها في الدرس السابق.
ما سنحصل عليه هو خوارزمية Shor، التي تسمح بتحليل الأعداد الصحيحة
بتكلفة متعددة الحدود أو في زمن متعدد الحدود إذا فضلنا
التفكير من حيث الزمن المطلوب بدلاً من عدد
العمليات الأساسية التي نحتاجها.
هذه هي جوهرة التاج في
الخوارزميات الكمية بمعنى ما، وبينما تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة الكبيرة
قد يكون محدود الفائدة لمعظم الناس، إلا أنها تبقى واحدة من أكثر
الأدلة إقناعاً التي لدينا على فرضية أن الحواسيب الكمية ستقدم
مزايا مذهلة
مقارنة بالحواسيب الكلاسيكية. إليكم نظرة عامة على الدرس.
سنبدأ بتعريف مسألة تقدير الطور نفسها، ثم سنناقش طريقة لحل هذه المسألة
باستخدام حاسوب كمي.
سنأخذها خطوة بخطوة، بدءاً بما يمكنكم
اعتباره نوعاً من التمهيد.
في مسألة تقدير الطور، الهدف هو تقريب
عدد حقيقي معين وفي هذا الجزء التمهيدي
سنرى كيف يمكننا الحصول على
تقريب بدقة منخفضة جداً
لهذا العدد.
هذا لن يكون كافياً
لعملية التحليل عندما نطبق حلنا لمسألة
تقدير الطور على تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة،
سنحتاج فعلياً إلى تقريب بدقة عالية جداً، لكن من المفيد مع ذلك البدء بهذا النوع من التمهيد
فقط لنأخذ فكرة عن
كيفية عمل الأمر برمته.
ثم سنناقش مسألة كيف يمكننا الحصول على دقة أعلى، وهذا سيقودنا بشكل
طبيعي جداً إلى عملية تُعرف بتحويل Fourier الكمي.
سنرى بالضبط ما هي هذه العملية وكيف يمكن تنفيذها
بدارة كمية.
وبمجرد أن نحصل عليها، سنتمكن من تطبيقها
على تقدير الطور للتوصل إلى إجراء عام لحل المسألة
بدقة عالية جداً.
ثم في الجزء الأخير من الدرس، سنرى كيف يتيح لنا حل
مسألة تقدير الطور تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة بكفاءة.
وتحديداً ما سنحصل عليه هو خوارزمية Shor لتحليل
الأعداد الصحيحة، أو على الأقل شيء مكافئ لخوارزمية Shor.
طريقة عمل ذلك هي أننا نعطي
أنفسنا حجر أساس، وهو مسألة أخرى تُسمى مسألة إيجاد الرتبة.
وبشكل خاص سنرى كيف يمكننا حل مسألة إيجاد الرتبة باستخدام إجراء تقدير الطور ثم سنرى كيف
يمكننا تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة
عن طريق حل مسألة إيجاد الرتبة. سنبدأ بحالة خاصة من نظرية تُسمى النظرية الطيفية،
وتحديداً سنركز على ما تخبرنا به النظرية
بالنسبة للمصفوفات الأحادية.
النظرية الطيفية هي
نظرية مهمة جداً من الجبر الخطي و
التحليل الدالي.
تخبرنا بشيء مثير للاهتمام حول كيفية التعبير عن تحويلات خطية معينة بشكل محدد، وغالباً ما يُسمى
التفكيك الطيفي،
وهو مفيد لأسباب كثيرة.
وكما قلت، سنركز على ما تخبرنا به هذه النظرية
بالنسبة للمصفوفات الأحادية.
النظرية الطيفية
أعم من هذا. لا تعمل مع جميع المصفوفات، لكنها تعمل مع فئة من المصفوفات
تُسمى المصفوفات العادية، والتي تشمل جميع المصفوفات الأحادية وكذلك بعض المصفوفات
التي ليست أحادية.
لكن فقط لتبسيط الأمور، سنقصر اهتمامنا
على المصفوفات الأحادية الآن لأن هذا كل ما نحتاجه
لأغراض هذا الدرس.
إليكم صيغة النظرية الطيفية فقط للمصفوفات الأحادية.
لنفترض أن U هي مصفوفة
أحادية من الحجم N في N.
ما تقوله النظرية
هو أنه يجب أن توجد قاعدة متعامدة معيارية من
المتجهات، psi واحد حتى psi N،
مع N عدد مركب
Lambda واحد حتى Lambda N، جميعها على دائرة الوحدة المركبة بحيث يمكن التعبير عن U
كما في هذه المعادلة.
هذا يُسمى التفكيك الطيفي
لـ U، كما ذكرت سابقاً، ويمكن أن يكون من المريح جداً معرفة أن U يمكن كتابتها بهذه الطريقة.
يمكن أن يكون من المريح أحياناً الحصول على هذه المتجهات وهذه الأعداد عندما نعمل مع
مصفوفة أحادية معينة U، ويمكن أيضاً أن يكون
مفيداً جداً ببساطة معرفة
أن مثل هذا التعبير ممكن دائماً كطريقة لإثبات أشياء معينة حول المصفوفات الأحادية مثلاً.
في هذه الصيغة للنظرية، كل من هذه الأعداد،
Lambda واحد حتى Lambda N، مكتوب بطريقة معينة
كـ E أس اثنين pi I ضرب theta حيث كل من thetas
theta واحد حتى theta N هو عدد حقيقي، و
سنعود لهذه الطريقة
في كتابة كل من هذه
الأعداد بعد قليل.
شيء مهم يجب ملاحظته
حول هذه المتجهات والأعداد هو أن كل متجه psi
K يجب أن يكون متجهاً ذاتياً للمصفوفة U مع
القيمة الذاتية المقابلة lambda K.
مما يعني أنه إذا
ضربنا psi K في U، ما نحصل عليه هو lambda K ضرب psi K.
فما تفعله U بكل من هذه المتجهات هو ببساطة ضربه بالعدد المقابل lambda K.
بشكل عام لمتجه عشوائي، لن تعمل U بهذه الطريقة، لكن المتجهات الذاتية خاصة.
وما تخبرنا به النظرية هو أنه يوجد فعلاً
قاعدة متعامدة معيارية من هذه المتجهات الذاتية.
هذه المعادلة هنا بالأسفل بالمناسبة، تنتج من التعبير الذي لدينا لـ U من النظرية، مع حقيقة أن
المتجهات متعامدة معيارية.
إذا ضربت
تعبير U في أي psi K واستخدمت تعامد المتجهات، ستحصل على مجموع جميع
حدوده تساوي صفراً
ما عدا واحد منها، والحد الوحيد المتبقي
يبدو هكذا.
الآن يمكننا تعريف
مسألة تقدير الطور.
المسألة غير اعتيادية
بعض الشيء كما سنرى.
نُعطى شيئين. أولاً، نُعطى وصف دارة كمية أحادية،
تعمل على N من الـ qubits
لاختيار معين لـ N، وعندما نقول أن هذه
دارة أحادية،
نعني ببساطة أن جميع
الـ gates أحادية، فلا توجد قياسات
في هذه الدارة.
ثانياً، نُعطى حالة من N من الـ qubits وهي psi، وهذا هو الجزء غير الاعتيادي.
لدينا فعلاً مُدخل
حالة كمية لهذه المسألة، وهي نسخة واحدة من هذه الحالة.
لجميع المسائل الحسابية الأخرى التي تحدثنا عنها في هذه السلسلة، كان المُدخل كلاسيكياً، إما على شكل سلسلة
من البتات أو كصندوق أسود.
وهذا ليس مفاجئاً لأن المسائل الحسابية
التي نصادفها في حياتنا اليومية تميل لأن تكون كلاسيكية،
لأن هذه هي المسائل
التي نهتم بها أكثر.
الطريقة التي يمكنكم
التفكير بها في هذه المسألة هي أنها شيء يظهر أو من المرجح أن يظهر كمسألة فرعية.
وإجراء تقدير الطور الذي سنتوصل إليه في النهاية هو شيء
نستخدمه عموماً كروتين فرعي
داخل حساب أكبر، على الأرجح لمسألة كلاسيكية
نهتم بها.
الآن، ستكون هذه مسألة وعد والحالة psi ليست
مجرد أي حالة كمية عادية.
نحن موعودون بأن psi هي متجه ذاتي لأي عملية أحادية U تصفها الدارة المعطاة.
والهدف هو إيجاد أو
تقريب القيمة الذاتية التي تقابل المتجه الذاتي psi.
لنصيغ المسألة بشكل
أكثر دقة قليلاً.
يتكون المُدخل من دارة
كمية أحادية على N من الـ qubits، يمكن ترميزها كسلسلة من البتات
باستخدام أي طريقة نفضلها لترميز أوصاف الدارات الكمية، مع حالة من N من الـ qubits وهي psi.
يمكننا تسمية الدارة ما نشاء، لكن ما يهم فعلاً من حيث صياغة هذه المسألة هو العملية الأحادية نفسها
التي تُنفذ عند تشغيل الدارة، وتلك العملية الأحادية
موصوفة بالمصفوفة U.
لكننا لم نُعطَ U كمصفوفة، بل أُعطينا فقط وصف دارة كمية تنفذ U.
الوعد، كما ذكرت سابقاً، هو أن psi هي متجه ذاتي لـ U.
فلو شغلنا دارتنا على psi، سنحصل على psi مضروبة بأي قيمة ذاتية كانت،
والتي ستكون طوراً شاملاً
في تلك الحالة.
وأخيراً، مخرج المسألة هو تقريب للقيمة الذاتية المقابلة لـ psi، وتحديداً نبحث عن
تقريب للعدد الحقيقي theta، بين الصفر والواحد، شاملاً
الصفر، لكن لا يشمل الواحد
الذي يحقق المعادلة
الموجودة على الشاشة.
لشرح طريقة
تحديد معاملات القيمة الذاتية المقابلة لـ psi، ولتوضيح ما نعنيه بالتقريب،
لنرسم صورة لدائرة
الوحدة المركبة.
يمكننا وضع الأعداد واحد، I،
سالب واحد، وسالب I في أماكنها المعتادة ويمكننا النظر في
نقطة عشوائية على
الدائرة محددة بـ theta كما في صياغة المسألة.
هذه هي النقطة التي
نحصل عليها إذا بدأنا من واحد ودُرنا بزاوية
اثنين ضرب pi ضرب theta، فالزاوية ليست
theta، بل اثنين pi theta،
وطريقة أخرى للتفكير فيها هي أنه إذا بدأنا من واحد وقطعنا مسافة اثنين pi theta على الدائرة نفسها،
سنصل إلى نقطتنا، E أس
اثنين ضرب pi ضرب theta.
كل نقطة على دائرة الوحدة المركبة يمكن تمثيلها بهذه الطريقة
لاختيار فريد من theta.
وذلك لأننا نلف
حول الدائرة بالكامل عندما تنتقل theta من صفر إلى واحد، وإذا وصلنا
إلى theta تساوي واحد،
سنعود من حيث
بدأنا عند theta تساوي صفر، ولهذا نشمل الصفر لكن لا نشمل الواحد.
فقط للتأكد من أن كل
نقطة على دائرة الوحدة المركبة تقابل قيمة فريدة من theta في المجال الذي ننظر فيه.
هناك طرق مختلفة
يمكننا تخيلها لتقريب قيمة معينة من theta، لكن الطريقة التي سنتبعها هي تقريب theta بكسر،
حيث المقام
هو اثنان أس M لاختيار معين لعدد صحيح موجب M، والبسط هو عدد صحيح y
بين صفر واثنين أس M ناقص واحد.
يمكنكم التفكير في هذا كتقريب بـ m بت لـ theta إذا أردتم، ويمكننا كتابة هذا
العدد بالترميز الثنائي
حيث لدينا فاصلة ثنائية متبوعة بالتمثيل الثنائي
لـ Y.
أقول فاصلة ثنائية بالمناسبة
بدلاً من فاصلة عشرية لأن العشري يعني أساس 10 وأنا أتحدث عن أساس اثنين
هنا، لكن الفكرة نفسها.
لكن في كل الأحوال يمكننا
أيضاً التفكير فيه ككسر كما
يظهر على الشاشة.
وللتوضيح، عندما نفكر في
التقريبات في هذا السياق، يجب أن نفهم
أن قيم theta
القريبة من الصفر وقيم theta القريبة من الواحد هي في الحقيقة قريبة من بعضها.
فمثلاً، إذا كانت theta تساوي 0.99 وقربنا هذه القيمة
من theta بالقيمة صفر،
فهذا تقريب جيد جداً بمعنى أنه
ضمن واحد من المئة من القيمة الفعلية، عندما
نلف حول الدائرة
ونعود إلى الصفر عندما نصل إلى الواحد.
يُستخدم مصطلح "بالقياس واحد" أحياناً لوصف هذا الموقف، حيث نساوي
أساساً theta تساوي واحد مع theta تساوي صفر.
النقطة هي أننا نهتم فعلاً بموقع النقطة
E أس اثنين pi I theta على دائرة الوحدة،
والتفكير بهذه
الطريقة في تقريب theta منطقي عندما يكون هذا هدفنا.
صياغة المسألة نفسها،
كما تظهر على الشاشة، لا تحدد مدى جودة التقريب المطلوب لـ theta،
لكن هذا شيء يمكننا ضبطه حسب احتياجاتنا.
في بعض الحالات قد نكتفي بتقريب منخفض الدقة
لـ theta، وفي حالات أخرى قد نطلب
تقريباً عالي الدقة جداً، ويمكن تنقيح صياغة المسألة
وفقاً لذلك.
بعد ذلك سنرى كيف يمكننا حل
مسألة تقدير الطور بحاسوب كمي و
سنبدأ بالتمهيد.
هذا لن يكون حلنا النهائي
للمسألة.
ما سنفعله هو استخدام ظاهرة ارتداد الطور لمحاولة تعلم شيء
عن القيمة الذاتية المقابلة لمتجه ذاتي معين.
تذكروا أنه في مسألة
تقدير الطور نُعطى وصف
دارة كمية أحادية لعملية ما U،
وما نفعله أولاً هو
استخدام وصف هذه الدارة لإنشاء دارة جديدة تنفذ عملية U متحكم بها كما
هو موضح على الشاشة.
هذا بسيط جداً. ما يمكننا فعله هو إضافة qubit تحكم، الموضح في
الأعلى في هذا المخطط
واستخدام qubit التحكم الجديد هذا
كمتحكم لكل gate يظهر
في دارتنا.
فجميع الـ gates تُطبق إذا كان qubit التحكم مضبوطاً على واحد، ولا يُطبق أي منها إذا كان qubit التحكم مضبوطاً على صفر،
وهذا يعني أننا
سنحتاج نسخة متحكم بها من كل gate يظهر
في الدارة U، لكن لا نحتاج التفكير
في هذه الـ gates المتحكم بها الجديدة
كـ gates مفردة إذا لم نرد. يمكن تنفيذها
كدارات صغيرة مكونة من gates من أي مجموعة gates
اخترنا استخدامها. وبمجرد أن يكون لدينا
نسخة متحكم بها من U، يمكننا النظر في تشغيل هذه الدارة،
حيث نضع أولاً qubit التحكم في تراكب من صفر وواحد، نطبق gate الـ U المتحكم بها على المتجه الذاتي psi المعطى لنا،
ثم نطبق gate الـ Hadamard
على المتحكم ونقيس.
سنرى لماذا من المنطقي فعل هذا أثناء التحليل، لكن حتى قبل الدخول في التفاصيل، يمكننا رؤية تشابه مباشر
مع خوارزمية Deutsch مثلاً، حيث نطبق
بضع gates Hadamard ونقيس كطريقة
للاستقصاء فعلياً عن
ما تفعله عملية معينة
هنا.
إنها عملية أحادية متحكم بها
بدلاً من gate استعلام، لكن هناك أفكار متشابهة جداً في العمل.
فلنرَ ما تفعله الدارة.
الحالة الابتدائية هي المتجه الذاتي psi، مضروبة تنسورياً بحالة الصفر
لـ qubit التحكم،
تطبيق gate الـ Hadamard الأولى يحول حالة
الـ qubit العلوي إلى حالة زائد ويمكننا توسيع الحالة
الكاملة كما هو موضح هنا.
ثم نطبق عملية الـ U المتحكم بها وما تفعله هو تطبيق U على psi عندما يكون qubit التحكم مضبوطاً على واحد،
لكن ليس عندما يكون مضبوطاً على صفر. فنحصل على الحالة pi اثنان
المكتوبة على الشاشة.
يمكننا تبسيط الحالة
باستخدام حقيقة أن psi هي متجه ذاتي لـ U بقيمة ذاتية e أس اثنين pi I theta.
فنحصل على تلك القيمة الذاتية مضروبة بالحد الثاني،
لكن ليس الأول.
ويمكننا التبسيط باستخدام الخطية الثنائية
للجداء التنسوري.
فما لدينا هنا هو
ظاهرة ارتداد الطور، لكن هذه المرة تحدث لمتجه ذاتي عشوائي psi لعملية أحادية عشوائية U،
بدلاً من عملية NOT مطبقة على حالة ناقص
بشكل أكثر تحديداً.
هذه هي الحالة بعد تطبيق عملية الـ U المتحكم بها.
بالمناسبة، يستحق
التوقف لملاحظة أن حالة الـ N qubits السفلية لا تزال المتجه الذاتي psi.
وهذا رائع لأنه
يمنحنا الفرصة لاستخدامها مرة أخرى إذا أردنا.
ثم تُنفذ gate الـ Hadamard الثانية وهذه هي الحالة التي نحصل عليها.
ولم أُظهر كل تفاصيل
الاشتقاق هنا، لكن إذا طبقتم
gate الـ Hadamard وبسطتم، هذا ما يجب أن تحصلوا عليه.
هذه هي الحالة قبل
القياس مباشرة.
فيمكننا التركيز على هذه الحالة لنرى ما يمكننا تعلمه
عن theta بالقياس.
وإذا قسنا الـ qubit العلوي
أو الـ qubit الأيمن، هذه هي الاحتمالات التي نحصل عليها للنتيجتين.
وهنا استخدمت
بعض الصيغ الأساسية التي تربط الجيوب وجيوب التمام
بالأسيات المركبة للتعبير عن هذه الاحتمالات
بدلالة الجيوب وجيوب التمام.
تحديداً، احتمال الحصول على صفر هو مربع جيب التمام لـ pi ضرب theta واحتمال الحصول على واحد
هو مربع الجيب لنفس الزاوية. وهذا منطقي
لأن مربع الجيب زائد مربع جيب التمام لأي
زاوية يساوي واحد.
فاحتمالاتنا مجموعها
واحد كما نتوقع.
وهذا رسم بياني لهذه الاحتمالات كدالة في theta.
للتوضيح، هذا رسم بياني
للاحتمالات نفسها وليس رسماً بيانياً يصور توزيع احتمالي
واحد مثلاً.
مثلاً، إذا كانت theta
تساوي نصف، فإن احتمال أن
نحصل على النتيجة واحد المرسومة بالبنفسجي يساوي واحد
بينما احتمال
الحصول على النتيجة صفر، المرسومة بالأزرق، هو صفر.
من ناحية أخرى، إذا كانت theta تساوي ربع
أو ثلاثة أرباع، فإن كلتا النتيجتين متساويتان في الاحتمال.
وبالطبع لجميع اختيارات theta، مجموع الاحتمالات يساوي واحد كما لاحظنا سابقاً.
فنحن لا نتعلم بالضبط ما هي
theta من هذا الإجراء، لكنه يعطينا بعض
المعلومات عن theta.
وإذا تخيلنا موقفاً نكون فيه موعودين
بأن theta تساوي صفر أو theta تساوي نصف، هذا الإجراء سيخبرنا
بالضبط أي من
الاحتمالين هو.
هذه طريقة بسيطة يمكننا من خلالها استخدام ظاهرة ارتداد الطور لتعلم شيء عن القيمة الذاتية.
فكيف يمكننا تعلم المزيد
عن القيمة الذاتية؟
حسناً، هذا موقف يمكن أن يكون
الجهل فيه مرشدنا.
لأنه ليس هناك فعلاً
أشياء كثيرة يمكننا فعلها.
لا نعرف شيئاً تقريباً
عن المتجه الذاتي psi، ولا نعرف
الكثير أيضاً عن العملية U.
لدينا دارة لـ U، لكن على حد علمنا قد تكون
فوضى مروعة ومربكة لن نتمكن من فهمها
بفحصها.
لكن أحد الخيارات الطبيعية هو تشغيل الدارة عدة مرات.
بالتحديد، يمكننا محاولة فعل نفس الشيء تماماً الذي فعلناه للتو، إلا أنه بدلاً من تطبيق عملية U متحكم بها واحدة فقط،
نطبق تلك العملية مرتين. أو يمكننا تطبيقها أي عدد من المرات، لكن لنبدأ بمرتين
فقط لنرى ما يحدث.
حسناً، ما يحدث بسيط جداً
في الواقع. بتطبيق عملية
الـ U المتحكم بها مرتين، نحن فعلياً
نربّع القيمة الذاتية
لأنها ستُركل في
طور الـ qubit العلوي مرتين بدلاً من مرة واحدة.
وعندما نفكر في
احتمالات النتائج كدالة في theta، فنحن أساساً
نضاعف التردد.
لكل اختيار ممكن لـ theta، احتمالات النتائج
هي نفسها كما لو ضاعفنا theta ثم
أخذنا الجزء الكسري
للحصول على عدد بين صفر وواحد.
مثلاً، إذا كانت theta
تساوي نصف، فإن القيمة الذاتية هي سالب واحد.
فبتطبيق U مرتين نحن فعلياً نربّع القيمة الذاتية والنتيجة هي نفسها كما لو كانت theta تساوي صفر.
أي أن احتمال
النتيجة صفر، بالأزرق، يساوي واحد، واحتمال النتيجة واحد، بالبنفسجي، يساوي صفر.
هذا بسيط جداً، لكن يمكننا فعلاً الحصول على
بعض المعلومات الإضافية عن theta بفعل هذا.
مثلاً، إذا كنا نعلم مسبقاً أن theta تساوي صفر أو theta تساوي ربع، فهذه الدارة ستكشف لنا
أي من الاحتمالين هو.
من ناحية أخرى، لم نعد قادرين على التمييز بين حالة theta تساوي صفر وحالة theta تساوي نصف.
فهذا الإجراء ليس أفضل بشكل مطلق من السابق عندما
كان لدينا gate U متحكم بها واحدة لكن بتشغيل هذه الدارة أيضاً
يمكننا الحصول على معلومات إضافية.
ليس واضحاً على الفور
كيف يمكن التوفيق بين المعلومات الإضافية التي نحصل عليها بتكرار عملية الـ U المتحكم بها عدة مرات
والمعلومات التي نحصل
عليها بتنفيذها مرة واحدة فقط، وفي الحقيقة هناك طرق متعددة
يمكننا المتابعة بها.
مثلاً، هناك تقنية تُسمى تقدير الطور التكراري، والتي تتضمن تشغيل دارات مثل التي رأيناها،
مع بعض التعديلات الطفيفة عليها، للتوصل إلى تقريب لـ theta.
لكنني سأصف
ما يمكن تسميته نهجاً أكثر تقليدية، حيث نستخدم دارة كمية واحدة بها عدة qubits تحكم
تتحكم في أعداد مختلفة
من تكرارات العملية الأحادية U.
أولاً سأصف كيف يعمل
هذا لاثنين من qubits التحكم ثم بعد قليل سنعممه لأكثر من اثنين من qubits التحكم.
هذه دارة كمية
تستخدم اثنين من qubits التحكم.
الـ qubit العلوي للتحكم
يتحكم في عملية U واحدة بينما الـ qubit الثاني من الأعلى
يتحكم في نسختين من U.
فما نفعله هو دمج الدارتين اللتين رأيناهما سابقاً، بطريقة تستفيد من النسخة الواحدة
من المتجه الذاتي psi التي لدينا.
ستلاحظون مع ذلك
أن gates الـ Hadamard بعد عمليات
الـ U المتحكم بها قد أُزيلت ولا توجد قياسات بعد.
ما سنفعله هو أن
نرى كيف تعمل هذه الدارة ثم نكتشف
ما يجب فعله بالـ qubits العلويين
لنتعلم أكبر قدر ممكن عن القيمة theta التي
نحاول تقريبها.
بعد تنفيذ gates الـ Hadamard، حصلنا على الحالة الموضحة
على الشاشة.
وهذه ستكون طريقة مريحة لكتابة الحالة لنرى
ما يحدث بعد ذلك.
A صفر وA واحد هما بتات، وإذا فكرنا في الـ qubits العلويين كسجل من qubitين،
نفكر في A صفر، الذي يقابل الـ qubit العلوي على أنه البت الأقل أهمية، وA واحد الذي يقابل
الـ qubit السفلي للتحكم
على أنه البت الأكثر أهمية.
بعد تنفيذ عملية الـ U
المتحكم بها الأولى، نحصل على هذه الحالة.
الحالة الكلاسيكية المقابلة لـ qubit التحكم العلوي هي A صفر، فنتيجة ارتداد الطور
يمكن التعبير عنها بهذه الطريقة. ثم بعد عمليتي الـ U
المتحكم بها الثانية والثالثة
نحصل على هذه الحالة.
الفكرة نفسها كالأولى، إلا أننا هذه المرة نطبق عملية الـ U المتحكم بها مرتين.
فنضرب A واحد في اثنين في
الأس ليعكس ذلك.
والآن يمكننا تبسيط هذا التعبير بالتفكير في البتين
A واحد وA صفر معاً كعدد صحيح بين صفر و
ثلاثة باستخدام الترميز الثنائي.
أي عندما نفكر
في سلسلة البتين، A واحد A صفر، كترميز ثنائي
لعدد صحيح،
ما نحصل عليه هو اثنان
ضرب A واحد زائد A صفر.
والمفهوم هو
أنه عندما نكتب ket X، نتحدث عن X مكتوبة كسلسلة ثنائية بطول
اثنين باستخدام الترميز الثنائي.
والآن لنركز على
هذين الـ qubitين للتحكم لنكتشف ما يمكننا
تعلمه عن theta منهما عند هذه النقطة.
الـ N qubits المتبقية لا تزال
في نفس الحالة psi التي أُعطيناها أصلاً، وهو شيء رائع
حقاً في هذا النهج
لأنه كما قلت سابقاً، يمكننا استخدام تلك الحالة مرة أخرى إذا أردنا الحصول على مزيد من
المعلومات عن theta.
لكن الآن، لنفكر فقط فيما يمكننا تعلمه من
هذين الـ qubitين للتحكم.
لمساعدتنا في تحديد كيفية المتابعة، لنتخيل أننا موعودون بأن theta تساوي Y على أربعة
لعدد صحيح y بين صفر وثلاثة.
بشكل عام، theta قد لا
تكون إحدى هذه القيم الأربع، لكن هذه حالة طبيعية للنظر فيها.
رأينا في النسخة الأصلية بـ qubit تحكم واحد من الإجراء أنه إذا كنا موعودين بأن theta هي صفر أو نصف
الدارة ستكشف أيهما. ولاحظنا أيضاً أنه في النسخة حيث طبقنا عملية
الـ U المتحكم بها مرتين،
يمكننا التمييز بشكل مثالي بين حالة theta تساوي صفر وحالة theta
تساوي ربع.
فقد نأمل أنه بدارتنا الجديدة يمكننا التمييز بين هذه الحالات الأربع.
في الجوهر، ما نفعله
هو أننا نستخدم مفهوم مسألة الوعد
لتسهيل المسألة، حتى نتمكن من رؤية كيفية المتابعة.
وهذه ليست فكرة سيئة، بشكل عام. إذا كانت لديكم مسألة ولا
تعرفون كيف تحلونها، حاولوا تسهيلها.
إذا استطعتم حل المسألة الأسهل، البصيرة التي تكتسبونها قد تكون مفيدة في حل المسألة الأعم.
وإذا لم تستطيعوا حل المسألة الأسهل، فأنتم على الأرجح غير مستعدين
للمسألة الأعم.
فاستمروا في التسهيل
حتى تتمكنوا من الحل.
على كل حال، بالعودة لمسألتنا، لنعرّف حالة من qubitين لكل قيمة ممكنة لـ Y.
بعبارة أخرى، phi Y تساوي الحالة
الموضحة أعلى الشاشة عندما يُختار theta
تحديداً ليكون Y على أربعة.
وهذه هي تلك الحالات الأربع
مكتوبة بشكل صريح.
فقط للتكرار، إذا
كانت theta تساوي Y على أربعة لـ Y يساوي صفر، واحد، اثنان، أو
ثلاثة وشغلنا دارتنا،
سنتبقى بإحدى
هذه الحالات الأربع، أيهما يقابل
القيمة الصحيحة لـ Y.
ونريد فقط معرفة
أيها هي.
والسؤال هو، هل هذا ممكن؟
والجواب على هذا السؤال هو نعم، لأن هذه الحالات الأربع متعامدة.
إذا حسبتم الجداء الداخلي
بين أي زوج منها، ستحصلون على صفر.
ولأنها متعامدة، يمكن تمييزها بشكل مثالي بقياس إسقاطي.
وبالتحديد يمكننا
التعبير عن مثل هذا القياس بتعريف إسقاط واحد لكل متجه كما هو هنا.
هذا يعمل دائماً، في أي وقت
لدينا قاعدة متعامدة معيارية، ويمكنكم التحقق من ذلك
مقابل التعريفات التي رأيناها في الدرس الثالث
لهذه الحالة تحديداً
إذا أردتم ذلك. فنستنتج أنه من
الممكن إنجاز مهمتنا،
وهي تعلم قيمة Y من الحالة الموضحة
أعلى الشاشة.
وإذا أردنا فعل ذلك
بدارة كمية، يمكننا المتابعة كما سأشرح الآن.
أولاً يمكننا تعريف مصفوفة أحادية V أعمدتها هي المتجهات الأربعة
المذكورة بالترتيب.
تلك المصفوفة سيكون لها الفعل الموصوف أسفل الشاشة،
على حالات القاعدة المعيارية،
ويمكننا كتابة المصفوفة
لنرى شكلها.
لأن V تحوّل كل حالة قاعدة معيارية، ket Y إلى المتجه phi Y، فإن بتطبيق V dagger،
أو بعبارة أخرى V المعكوسة على phi Y سنعيد التحويل بالاتجاه الآخر إلى حالة القاعدة المعيارية المقابلة.
فما يمكننا فعله هو تطبيق V dagger على أي حالة
حصلنا عليها من دارتنا.
وبعد ذلك إذا أجرينا
قياس القاعدة المعيارية، سنحصل على العدد Y
الذي نبحث عنه، معبراً عنه كسلسلة
بطول اثنين بالنظام الثنائي.
قبل أن نذهب أبعد، لنتحدث قليلاً أكثر
عن المصفوفة الأحادية V.
هذه مصفوفة مميزة وربما
رأيتموها من قبل.
هي المصفوفة المرتبطة
بعملية خطية على متجهات رباعية الأبعاد تُعرف بتحويل Fourier المتقطع.
لنكون أكثر دقة، يمكن تعريف تحويل Fourier المتقطع لأي
بُعد عدد صحيح موجب، وسنلقي نظرة عليه
بشكل عام بعد لحظات.
وهذا هو شكله تحديداً
عندما يكون البُعد يساوي أربعة.
يمكننا التفكير في
تحويل Fourier المتقطع بطرق مختلفة.
يمكننا التفكير فيه بشكل مجرد تماماً كتحويل خطي على المتجهات يمكن تمثيله بمصفوفة.
ويمكننا أيضاً التفكير
فيه كمسألة حسابية حيث نُعطى متجهاً، ونريد حساب نتيجة
تطبيق هذا التحويل الخطي.
وتبين أن هذه مسألة حسابية
مهمة للغاية، وهناك خوارزمية عالية الكفاءة لإجراء هذا الحساب
تُعرف بتحويل Fourier السريع.
في الحقيقة، هذه مسألة مهمة جداً في معالجة الإشارات مثلاً، لدرجة أن تحويل Fourier
السريع يعتبره كثيرون
واحداً من أهم الخوارزميات وأكثرها تأثيراً
التي اكتُشفت على الإطلاق.
يمكننا أيضاً التفكير في
تحويل Fourier المتقطع كعملية كمية أحادية يمكن تطبيقها على
متجه حالة كمية.
وعندما نفكر فيه بهذه الطريقة، نسميه تحويل Fourier
الكمي، أو QFT اختصاراً.
رياضياً، هو نفس الشيء تقريباً كتحويل Fourier المتقطع، لكننا نسميه
تحويل Fourier الكمي
فقط لتوضيح أنها عملية تُطبق على متجه حالة كمية.
فلنغير اسم مصفوفتنا، من V إلى QFT أربعة ليعكس حقيقة
أن العملية التي توصلنا إليها هي فعلاً تحويل Fourier الكمي.
إليكم الدارة الكاملة لتعلم قيمة Y عندما نكون موعودين بأن
theta تساوي Y على أربعة
لـ Y يساوي صفر، واحد، اثنان، أو ثلاثة.
وللتوضيح، نحن نطبق معكوس
تحويل Fourier الكمي، أو بعبارة أخرى QFT أربعة dagger
لتحويل إحدى الحالات الأربع الممكنة إلى حالة القاعدة المعيارية، ket Y، حتى نتمكن من استرداد Y بالقياس.
هذه هي الدارة التي
نحصل عليها من التفكير في النسخة الموعودة لمسألة
تقدير الطور، حيث نحن موعودون بأن theta
هي صفر، ربع، نصف،
أو ثلاثة أرباع، لكن لا شيء يمنعنا
من تشغيل هذه الدارة
لقيمة عشوائية من theta.
وإذا فعلنا ذلك، هذه
هي الاحتمالات للنتائج الأربع الممكنة
التي نحصل عليها.
كل قيمة من القيم الأربع
الممكنة لـ Y لها لونها الخاص، والرسم البياني يخبرنا
بالاحتمالات لكل واحدة كدالة في theta.
فمثلاً، إذا كانت theta
تساوي ثلاثة أرباع، سنحصل على النتيجة
ثلاثة باحتمال واحد،
بينما احتمالات النتائج الثلاث الأخرى كلها صفر كما نعلم سابقاً من التفكير في النسخة الموعودة للمسألة.
إذا كانت theta قريبة من ثلاثة أرباع لكن ليست بالضبط ثلاثة أرباع، سيكون هناك بعض الاحتمال غير الصفري مرتبط بالنتائج الأخرى،
لكن سنظل نحصل على النتيجة
ثلاثة باحتمال عالٍ.
فحتى لو لم تكن theta
تساوي Y على أربعة، لا يزال بإمكاننا التفكير
في النتيجة التي نحصل عليها من القياسات مقسومة على أربعة
على أنها تخمين أو
تقريب لـ theta.
التخمين قد يكون خاطئاً، لكنه مع ذلك
يزودنا بمعلومات.
وشيء واحد يمكننا
تعلمه من الرسم البياني هو أن أفضل التقريبات دائماً لديها أعلى
الاحتمالات المرتبطة بها.
عندما أقول أفضل تقريب، أعني أي قيمة من Y على أربعة هي الأقرب للقيمة الحقيقية لـ theta،
بمعنى القياس واحد. أسوأ حالة ممكنة هي أن تكون theta في منتصف المسافة بالضبط بين
قيمتين من Y على أربعة.
مثلاً، إذا كانت theta تساوي
ثلاثة أثمان أو 0.375، في هذه الحالة نرى
أن التقريبين
ربع واثنان على أربعة
أو نصف متساويان في الجودة.
ففي هذه الحالة
بالذات هناك فعلاً تقريبان أفضل بدلاً من واحد.
ونحصل بالتساوي على النتيجة واحد
والنتيجة اثنان.
النتيجتان الأخريان صفر وثلاثة، اللتان لا تعطيان تقريبات
جيدة لـ theta عند القسمة على أربعة، تظهران فعلاً بشيء من الاحتمال
الذي يبدو أقل بقليل
من 10% في كلتا الحالتين.
فهذا الإجراء ليس مثالياً، لكنه يزودنا بمعلومات.
ومن الجدير بالملاحظة أنه
بغض النظر عن theta، نحن مضمونون دائماً بالحصول على أفضل تقريب
أو أحد أفضل تقريبين عند التعادل، باحتمال
يبدو أعلى بقليل من 40%.
وكلما كانت theta
أقرب للتقريب، كلما زاد احتمال رؤية القيمة المقابلة لـ Y.
وهذا تحسن كبير
جداً مقارنة باستخدام qubit تحكم واحد.
هذا هو فعلاً إجراء تقدير
الطور عندما نختار استخدام اثنين من qubits التحكم.
وما سنفعله بعد ذلك هو تعميم هذا
الإجراء بطريقة طبيعية، حيث لا نتوقف عند
اثنين فقط من qubits التحكم
بل نستخدم العدد الذي نريده
من qubits التحكم.
وما سنراه هو أنه
بتعميم الإجراء، بإضافة المزيد من qubits التحكم، سنتمكن من الحصول على تقريبات أدق وأدق
لـ theta. وهذا سيكون إجراء
تقدير الطور العام.
لتعميم إجراء
تقدير الطور من اثنين من qubits التحكم
إلى العدد الذي نريده، سنحتاج لفهم
كيف يُعرَّف تحويل Fourier الكمي لأبعاد أخرى.
وسنحتاج أيضاً لمناقشة كيف يمكن تنفيذه
بدارة كمية.
إليكم تعريف تحويل
Fourier الكمي عندما يكون البُعد عدداً
صحيحاً موجباً عشوائياً N.
هنا نفكر في هذه العملية كعملية على نظام حالاته الكلاسيكية هي
صفر حتى N ناقص واحد.
وهنا المصفوفة التي
تصف هذه العملية تم التعبير عنها باستخدام
ترميز Dirac.
يمكننا أيضاً وصفها من حيث تأثيرها
على حالات القاعدة المعيارية، لربطها بما
رأيناه سابقاً عندما N يساوي أربعة.
هذا شكلها
عندما N يساوي واحد، وهي ليست حالة مثيرة جداً.
هذا لـ N يساوي اثنان، وستلاحظون أن ما نحصل عليه في هذه الحالة هو عملية Hadamard.
هذا تحويل Fourier
الكمي لـ N يساوي ثلاثة.
لـ N يساوي أربعة، الذي
رأيناه سابقاً.
ولمثال أخير، هذا هو عندما N يساوي ثمانية.
تماماً كما كان لدينا
لحالة N يساوي أربعة، هذه هي المصفوفات التي نربطها بتحويل Fourier المتقطع
لكل من الأبعاد. لكن نسميه
تحويل Fourier الكمي عندما نريد التفكير
فيه كعملية كمية.
أحياناً بالمناسبة، العامل الأول واحد على الجذر التربيعي لـ N لا يُضمَّن عندما نفكر في تحويل Fourier
المتقطع كمصفوفة،
لكننا نحتاج ذلك العامل هنا للتأكد من أننا نحصل على مصفوفة أحادية.
هناك أيضاً أحياناً إشارة سالبة في كل من الأسس، لكن ليس دائماً.
هذا أساساً مجرد تفضيل شخصي لا يغير الطبيعة
الأساسية للتحويل.
لكن في كل الأحوال، سنعرّف تحويل Fourier الكمي كما هو مكتوب هنا على الشاشة.
هناك ترميز مختصر مفيد جداً
وشائع وسنستخدمه
لاحقاً في الدرس.
وهو تعريف عدد
مركب omega N، كما هو هنا.
تحديداً كـ e أس اثنين pi I على N، والذي يمكن كتابته أيضاً
باستخدام الجيوب وجيوب التمام
كما هو هنا. أحياناً نسمي هذا
العدد جذر N للوحدة لأنه عندما نرفعه
للقوة N، نحصل على واحد.
هذا شكل يوضح بعض الأمثلة.
omega واحد يساوي واحد، omega اثنان يساوي سالب واحد، وomega أربعة يساوي I.
بشكل عام للحصول على omega N، يمكننا تخيل تقطيع دائرة الوحدة إلى N قطع متساوية كأنها بيتزا تُقاسم بين N شخص
وomega N عند
زاوية القطعة الأولى، بافتراض أن الزاوية الأخرى
لتلك القطعة عند الواحد.
فبالتحديد كلما كبر N
أكثر وأكثر، ستصبح القطع أصغر وأصغر، وomega N ستقترب
أكثر وأكثر من الواحد.
والآن باستخدام هذا الترميز يمكننا التعبير عن
تحويل Fourier الكمي بطريقة أنظف قليلاً.
أحياناً هذا الترميز
يساعد في تبسيط الأمور كما سنرى
لاحقاً في الدرس.
هناك تنفيذ فعّال بدارة كمية
لتحويل Fourier الكمي
عندما يكون N قوة لاثنين،
وسنلقي نظرة عليه الآن. رغم أننا نميل لتعريف
تحويل Fourier الكمي لأي بُعد N،
فنحن نحتاجه فقط
في حالة أن N قوة لاثنين، من أجل تعميم
إجراء تقدير الطور.
التنفيذ سيستخدم
gates طور متحكم بها والتي تُصوَّر كما
هو على الشاشة.
تبدو كمتحكمين
متصلين ببعضهما مع رقم وهو
alpha في هذه الحالة.
وتأثير هذه الـ gate موصوف بالمصفوفة الموضحة هنا.
هذه حرفياً
gates طور متحكم بها، بمعنى أن لدينا qubit تحكم يتحكم في gate طور.
رأينا gates الطور في بداية الدرس الأول.
لكن بالنسبة لـ gates الطور تحديداً، لا يهم فعلاً
أي qubit هو المتحكم وأيها الهدف.
ورأينا ذلك في الدرس الثاني، لحالة Z gate تحديداً.
والآن بعد أن لدينا هذا المفهوم، يمكننا الانتقال لكيفية
تنفيذ تحويل Fourier الكمي.
التنفيذ تكراري بطبيعته وربما أسهل طريقة
لوصفه بعبارات بسيطة هي إعطاء مثال يمكن
تعميمه بسهولة.
هكذا يمكننا فعله
عندما N يساوي 32.
فهناك خمسة qubits.
للتوضيح، نحن نربط
حالات القاعدة المعيارية لهذه الـ qubits الخمسة بالأعداد الصحيحة بين صفر و31 باستخدام الترميز الثنائي.
أول شيء نفعله هو تنفيذ تحويل Fourier
الكمي لـ N يساوي 16 على جميع الـ qubits عدا
الـ qubit الأقل أهمية،
وهو الذي في الأعلى. وهذا هو الجزء التكراري
من البناء.
فلتنفيذ هذه العملية، يجب اتباع نفس
النمط لكن بعدد أقل بواحد من الـ qubits.
وفي الحالة الأساسية لدينا
qubit واحد فقط وفيه تحويل Fourier الكمي هو مجرد gate Hadamard.
بمجرد تطبيق QFT على جميع الـ qubits عدا العلوي، نطبق مجموعة من gates الطور المتحكم بها باستخدام الأطوار
المبينة في المخطط.
ثم نطبق gate Hadamard
على الـ qubit العلوي، ونعيد ترتيب الـ qubits قليلاً باستخدام بعض gates التبديل.
gates التبديل هذه لها تأثير التبديل الدوري للـ qubits وهو ضروري لجعل
البناء يعمل.
يمكننا اتباع نفس النمط بالضبط لاختيارات أخرى لـ N
بشرط أن تكون قوى لاثنين، حيث نبدأ دائماً gates الطور المتحكم بها
بـ alpha يساوي pi على
اثنين للـ qubit السفلي ونقسم على اثنين كل مرة
بالتحرك لليسار في المخطط
للحصول على الأطوار التالية. الآن ليس واضحاً على الإطلاق
أن هذا البناء يعمل.
ولن أشرح لماذا
يعمل في هذا الفيديو.
إذا كنتم مهتمين برؤية
التفاصيل لماذا يعمل، يمكنكم إيجادها في
المحتوى المكتوب للدرس.
لكن سأقول إن ما
يُستغل هنا هو البنية الأساسية لتحويلات
Fourier المتقطعة
وفي الحقيقة هي نفس
البنية بالضبط التي تسمح لتحويل
Fourier السريع بالعمل.
طريقة أخرى لقول هذا هي أنه إذا نظرنا لتحويل Fourier السريع، يمكننا التفكير فيه من حيث
الدارات الكمية.
وهذه هي الدارة التي نحصل عليها.
فكم عدد الـ gates التي نحتاجها إجمالاً لهذا التنفيذ؟
لنكتشف ذلك، لنجعل SM هو عدد الـ gates التي
نحتاجها عندما يكون لدينا M من الـ qubits.
عندما M يساوي واحد، نحتاج gate واحدة فقط لأن QFT هو مجرد عملية Hadamard في هذه الحالة.
إذا كانت M اثنان على الأقل، فهذه
هي الـ gates التي نحتاجها.
أولاً نحتاج SM ناقص واحد gate لتحويل Fourier
الكمي على M ناقص واحد من الـ qubits، أياً كان هذا العدد.
نحتاج أيضاً M ناقص واحد
gate طور متحكم بها، M ناقص واحد gate تبديل،
وgate Hadamard إضافية واحدة.
فهذا تعبير عن
SM في كلتا الحالتين عندما M تساوي واحد و
عندما M اثنان على الأقل.
هذا مثال على ما يُسمى علاقة تكرارية و
تظهر كثيراً جداً في تحليل الخوارزميات.
هذه العلاقة بالذات
بسيطة جداً ولها ما يُسمى
تعبير صيغة مغلقة، يمكن الحصول عليه بالجمع.
لنكون دقيقين، قيمة SM هي مجموع أول M
أعداد فردية متتالية، والذي يساوي M تربيع،
كما ربما صادفتم ذلك سابقاً أو ربما لاحظتموه
في وقت ما في حياتكم.
ويتصادف أنه من السهل جداً إثبات هذه الصيغة بالاستقراء على M إذا
كنتم مهتمين ببرهان شكلي.
هذا كل شيء. يمكننا تنفيذ
تحويل Fourier الكمي على M من الـ qubits باستخدام M تربيع gate.
فقط بعض الملاحظات
الإضافية السريعة جداً.
أولاً لا نحتاج فعلاً
جميع gates التبديل التي وصفتها.
من الممكن فعلاً
دفعها كلها للنهاية طالما نعدّل الـ qubits التي تعمل عليها gates الطور المتحكم بها
بشكل مناسب.
وإذا فعلنا ذلك سنحتاج
فقط M على اثنين gate تبديل إجمالاً مع التقريب للأسفل.
سيظل لدينا تكلفة تربيعية، لكن يمكن تقليل عدد الـ gates بهذه الطريقة مع ذلك.
وملاحظة أخيرة هي أننا نستطيع فعلاً جعل التكلفة أقل إذا كنا مستعدين للقبول
بتقريب جيد جداً.
مثلاً، عندما تكبر M، كثير من gates الطور المتحكم بها تكون قريبة جداً من
عملية الهوية،
وحذف التي
هي قريبة جداً يمكن أن يوفر لنا كثيراً من الـ gates مع الاستمرار في إعطائنا
تقريباً جيداً جداً.
من الممكن أيضاً تقريب تحويل Fourier الكمي
بدارات ضحلة جداً، أي ذات عمق صغير، في حال كان هذا شيئاً
نرغب في فعله.
والآن بعد أن عرفنا ما هو
تحويل Fourier الكمي لأبعاد مختلفة، وكذلك كيف يمكن تنفيذه عندما يكون البُعد قوة لاثنين،
يمكننا العودة لإجراء
تقدير الطور ورؤية كيف يمكن تعميمه حيث نستخدم عدداً عشوائياً
M من qubits التحكم.
هذا شكل الإجراء كدارة كمية لاختيار
عشوائي لـ M.
لدينا M من qubits التحكم في الأعلى، والتي نفترض أنها جميعاً
مهيأة بحالة الصفر.
نطبق gate Hadamard
على كل واحد منها ثم كل واحد يُستخدم
كـ qubit تحكم لتطبيق قوة ما من
العملية الأحادية U،
حيث نضاعف عدد
مرات تطبيق U لكل qubit تحكم.
هنا في هذا المخطط أشرت لذلك بوضع القوى
على U داخل المربعات بدلاً من إظهار gate الـ U المتحكم بها
مطبقة هذا العدد من المرات، كطريقة لجعل
المخطط أوضح وتوفير المساحة حتى
يسع الشاشة.
الآن أول شيء يجب ملاحظته
حول هذا الإجراء هو أنه قد يصبح مكلفاً جداً.
بالتحديد نحن
نضاعف عدد مرات تطبيق كل عملية U
لكل qubit تحكم.
وإذا كانت طريقتنا في ذلك هي ببساطة تكرار gate الـ U المتحكم بها بالعدد المطلوب،
سنحصل على دارة ضخمة. ستكون أسية
في العدد M.
هذا قيد كبير بشكل عام، وبالتحديد يحد من قدرتنا على الحصول على تقريبات دقيقة
للقيم الذاتية.
لكن في الحالة المحددة للتحليل، التي سنصل إليها قريباً، يتبين أننا محظوظون جداً ويمكننا استخدام حيلة تسمح لنا
بتجنب هذا الانفجار الأسي في التكلفة.
لكن بشكل عام لعمليات
أحادية عشوائية U، هذا لن يكون ممكناً و
سندفع ثمناً باهظاً
لزيادة عدد
qubits التحكم.
لن أقوم بتحليل
مفصل للدارة في هذا الفيديو وبدلاً من ذلك سأذكر فقط أن هناك تعبيراً بسيطاً إلى حد ما
للحالة
قبل القياسات مباشرة وهو موضح هنا على الشاشة.
من تلك الحالة يمكننا الحصول على تعبير لاحتمالات
النتائج المختلفة، وهو يبدو هكذا.
وبمجرد حصولنا على هذا التعبير،
يمكننا التفكير فيه، وفعلاً هذا التعبير
هو كل ما نحتاجه للمتابعة.
كما قلت، لن أدخل في
التفاصيل في هذا الفيديو، لكن يمكنكم إيجادها في
المحتوى المكتوب للدرس ويتبين أنه
ليس معقداً فعلاً،
فراجعوه إذا أردتم. إذا قمنا بالتحليل، ما نجده هو أن الوضع
ليس مختلفاً كثيراً
عن حالة M تساوي اثنين، إلا أننا نحصل على دقة أعلى.
بالتحديد، يمكننا التفكير
أولاً في احتمال الحصول على أفضل تقريب أو أحد
أفضل تقريبين،
والذي يمكننا التعبير عنه كما هو هنا.
يمكنكم تجاهل الحرف السفلي واحد على القيمة المطلقة إذا أردتم.
هذا مجرد رمز يمكننا
استخدامه لتذكير أنفسنا بأننا نتحدث عن
تقريبات على الدائرة حيث نعتبر theta تساوي صفر
وtheta تساوي واحد نفس الشيء. النقطة هنا هي
أننا نفكر في أي اختيار لـ Y يجعل Y على اثنين أس M
أقرب ما يمكن لـ theta.
ومرة أخرى، تماماً كما
كان لحالة M تساوي اثنين، نحن مضمونون بالحصول على هذه النتيجة Y باحتمال 40% على الأقل.
في الحقيقة، الاحتمال هو
أربعة على pi تربيع على الأقل، وهو أكثر بقليل من 40%.
10 ليس تقريباً سيئاً
لـ pi تربيع عندما تكون في عجلة.
وهذا مذهل فعلاً. ما نتحدث عنه هو الحصول على أفضل
تقريب لـ theta ككسر Y على اثنين أس M
حيث Y عدد صحيح. ونحصل على
أفضل تقريب باحتمال أكبر من 40%.
يمكننا أيضاً التفكير في
تقريبات أسوأ.
تحديداً لنتخيل
أن Y ليست جيدة تماماً، وبالتحديد لنفترض
أن هناك تقريباً
أفضل لـ theta من نفس الشكل يقع بين theta وY على اثنين أس M،
والذي يمكن التعبير عنه
كما هو مكتوب على الشاشة.
في مثل هذه الحالة
احتمال الحصول على هذه Y سيكون صغيراً نسبياً، 25% على الأكثر.
سيكون فعلاً أقل من ذلك، لكن 25% هو ما نحصل عليه من
تحليل بسيط إلى حد ما، لكنه كافٍ.
كمثال. هذا الرسم البياني الذي نحصل عليه عند استخدام ثلاثة qubits
تحكم بدلاً من اثنين.
هذه المرة أرسم فقط
احتمالات النتائج ثلاثة، أربعة، وخمسة لأنني لا أريد
الشكل أن يكون فوضوياً جداً.
عندما theta تساوي
نصف مثلاً، نحن مضمونون بالحصول على النتيجة أربعة.
فنأخذ تقريبنا
ليكون أربعة أثمان أو نصف لأن اثنين
أس ثلاثة يساوي ثمانية.
وفي هذه الحالة نحن على صواب تماماً. وطالما theta أقرب لنصف منها مثلاً لثلاثة
أثمان،
نحصل على النتيجة أربعة باحتمال أعلى
من النتيجة ثلاثة.
وباحتمال،
مرة أخرى أكبر من 40%.
هذا الرسم البياني عندما M يساوي أربعة. والمنحنيات تبدو
متطابقة تقريباً، إلا أننا الآن قربنا
بمعامل اثنين.
فالآن النتائج المرسومة تشمل سبعة، ثمانية، وتسعة ونأخذ التقريب ليكون أحد هذه الأعداد
مقسومة على 16 بدلاً من ثمانية.
وسأعرض رسماً بيانياً آخر حيث نزيد لـ M يساوي خمسة.
ومرة أخرى سنقوم
بالتقريب بمعامل اثنين.
وها هو. مرة أخرى المنحنيات تبدو
متطابقة تقريباً، لكننا فعلياً
نضاعف دقتنا.
وكالسابق حصلنا على أفضل تقريب لـ theta، باحتمال أكبر من 40%.
هذا مذهل حقاً. لكن إذا لم تكن 40% كافية
كمقياس للثقة،
ما يمكننا فعله هو تشغيل الإجراء عدداً صغيراً من المرات، و
أخذ المنوال من النتائج، أي النتيجة التي
تظهر أكثر.
وإذا فعلنا ذلك، سنكون على الأرجح جداً بتقريب جيد جداً لـ theta.
تذكروا بالمناسبة أنه في كل مرة نشغل فيها
إجراء تقدير الطور نجد أن المتجه الذاتي
يخرج دون تغيير.
فهو متاح لنا لتشغيل الإجراء
عدة مرات هكذا.
باختصار، نحن نجمع
إحصائيات عن theta، والنقطة هي أنه بفعل هذا يمكننا الحصول على تقريب دقيق جداً
لـ theta
بثقة عالية جداً، ولا نحتاج كثيراً من تكرارات الإجراء لفعل ذلك.
وهكذا يعمل إجراء
تقدير الطور.
في الجزء الأخير من الدرس، سنطبق تقنية
تقدير الطور على مسألة تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة.
كما ذكرت في بداية الفيديو، طريقة عمل ذلك هي أننا ننظر في مسألة وسيطة تُعرف بمسألة إيجاد الرتبة.
سنرى كيف يمكننا حل
مسألة إيجاد الرتبة باستخدام تقدير الطور، ثم سنناقش باختصار كيف أن حل مسألة إيجاد الرتبة
يسمح لنا بتحليل الأعداد الصحيحة بكفاءة.
الجزء الثاني كلاسيكي بالكامل وسألخص فقط
الفكرة الأساسية في هذا الفيديو.
لكن لنبدأ بمسألة
إيجاد الرتبة.
أولاً، لنضع بعض
الترميز المفيد.
لكل عدد صحيح موجب N، نعرّف ZN على أنها الأعداد الصحيحة
صفر حتى N ناقص واحد.
فمثلاً، Z واحد لها عنصر
واحد وهو صفر، Z اثنان لها العنصران صفر وواحد،
Z ثلاثة لها العناصر صفر،
واحد واثنان، وهكذا.
فـ ZN هي مجموعة.
لكن يمكننا أيضاً التفكير
فيها كأكثر من مجموعة. يمكننا التفكير في العمليات الحسابية كالجمع والضرب على ZN
بتعريفها بالقياس N.
مثلاً، لنفترض أن
N يساوي سبعة.
لدينا ثلاثة وخمسة
عنصران في Z سبعة وإذا ضربناهما ببعض نحصل على 15
الذي يترك باقياً قدره
واحد بعد القسمة على سبعة.
أحياناً نعبر عن هذا بكتابة أن ثلاثة ضرب خمسة
متطابق مع واحد بالقياس سبعة، كما هو مكتوب هنا.
لكن يمكننا أيضاً ببساطة كتابة أن ثلاثة ضرب خمسة يساوي واحد.
بالطبع ثلاثة ضرب خمسة
لا يساوي عادة واحد، بل يساوي 15.
لكن عندما يكون واضحاً
أننا نعمل في Z سبعة بمعنى أن الضرب
معرّف بالقياس سبعة،
يمكننا ببساطة كتابة أن
ثلاثة ضرب خمسة يساوي واحد.
الآن من بين عناصر
ZN لأي N موجب، بعضها سيكون لها
القاسم المشترك الأكبر يساوي واحد مع N
وبعضها لا. والعناصر التي القاسم المشترك الأكبر لها يساوي واحد مع N هي مميزة.
ونكتب ZN نجمة للإشارة إلى مجموعة هذه العناصر فقط.
فمثلاً، هذه هي Z 21 نجمة.
من بين عناصر Z 21، وعددها 21 بالطبع، يتبين أن 12 منها القاسم المشترك الأكبر لها يساوي واحد
مع 21 والباقي لا.
بالتحديد في أي وقت يكون
لدينا عنصر من Z 21 قابل للقسمة على
ثلاثة أو سبعة، نتخطاه.
هناك أسباب متعددة
لكون هذه المجموعة مميزة، وأحد الأسباب هو أنه في أي وقت يكون لدينا عنصر من ZN نجمة
وننظر في القوى
الصحيحة الموجبة لذلك العدد، سنصل دائماً في النهاية
للعدد واحد،
حيث كالسابق نتحدث عن الضرب بالقياس N.
أصغر قوة صحيحة موجبة تعطينا واحد تُسمى
رتبة ذلك العنصر.
مثلاً، فكروا في العنصر A يساوي أربعة في Z 21 نجمة.
أربعة ضرب أربعة يساوي 16، وهو لا يساوي واحد بالقياس 21، لكن إذا ضربنا بأربعة مرة أخرى،
نحصل على 64، و64 بالقياس
21 يساوي واحد.
فرتبة أربعة بالقياس 21 هي ثلاثة.
الوصول إلى واحد هكذا يحدث دائماً لجميع عناصر ZN نجمة.
وبالمناسبة، لا يحدث أبداً
لعناصر ZN التي ليست في ZN نجمة.
فكون القاسم المشترك الأكبر
يساوي واحد مع N هكذا هو شرط ضروري و
كافٍ لحدوث هذا.
ولإنهاء مثال
N يساوي 21، هذه هي أصغر
القوى الصحيحة الموجبة التي يعمل بها هذا لكل
عنصر من Z 21 نجمة،
ويمكن التحقق من كل واحدة على حدة.
والآن يمكننا صياغة
مسألة إيجاد الرتبة، وهي ببساطة إيجاد الرتبة لعنصر معين في ZN نجمة.
لنكون دقيقين، المُدخل هو
عددان صحيحان موجبان A وN حيث القاسم المشترك الأكبر يساوي واحد،
والمخرج هو
أصغر عدد صحيح موجب R بحيث A أس R
متطابق مع واحد بالقياس N،
أو بشكل مكافئ
أصغر عدد صحيح موجب R بحيث A أس R يساوي واحد.
بافتراض أننا نجري الحسابات في ZN.
يُعتقد أن هذه مسألة
صعبة حسابياً، ولا تُعرف خوارزمية كلاسيكية
فعالة لحلها.
وكما سنناقش فإن المسألة صعبة على الأقل بقدر
تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة بمعنى أنه إذا كانت لدينا خوارزمية لحل مسألة إيجاد الرتبة،
سنتمكن من استخدام تلك الخوارزمية لحل مسألة تحليل
الأعداد الصحيحة بكفاءة.
في الحقيقة، الأمر يعمل بالاتجاه المعاكس أيضاً، بمعنى أنه إذا كانت لديكم خوارزمية للتحليل، يمكنكم استخدامها لحل
مسألة إيجاد الرتبة.
فالمسألتان بمعنى ما
متكافئتان من حيث
صعوبتهما الحسابية.
الآن سنرى كيف يمكننا حل
مسألة إيجاد الرتبة على حاسوب كمي
باستخدام تقدير الطور.
لإنشاء رابط بين المسألتين، لنتخيل أن لدينا نظاماً مجموعة حالاته الكلاسيكية هي ZN.
لأي اختيار لعنصر A في ZN نجمة، سنعرّف عملية
MA كما هو هنا.
بالكلمات ما تفعله MA هو الضرب في A، وهنا الضرب بالقياس N.
ولبقية هذا الدرس، يجب أن تفكروا دائماً في
التعبيرات داخل الـ kets على أنها محسوبة بالقياس N،
فقط لنبقي الأمور بسيطة ولا نضطر لكتابة
mod N مراراً وتكراراً.
هذه عملية أحادية، لكن هذا صحيح فقط
لأن A في ZN نجمة.
إذا كان القاسم المشترك الأكبر لـ A وN لا يساوي واحد، فهذه العملية لن تكون أحادية.
هذا مثال. إذا كانت N تساوي 15 وA يساوي اثنين، وهو في Z 15 نجمة، فهذا
هو تأثير M اثنين.
وإذا فحصتم هذا
المثال لبضع لحظات، سترون أن ما يحدث هو أن عناصر ZN يتم فقط تبديلها بهذا التأثير.
فهي حتمية وأحادية معاً، أي كمصفوفة، MA هي مصفوفة تبديل.
وهنا الفكرة الرئيسية. القيم الذاتية لـ MA مرتبطة
ارتباطاً وثيقاً
برتبة A. وباستخدام تقدير الطور لتقريب هذه
القيم الذاتية بدقة كافية
يمكننا تحديد رتبة A. فما هي بالضبط المتجهات الذاتية والقيم الذاتية لـ MA؟
حسناً، لن نحتاج كلها، نحتاج فقط بعضها.
لنبدأ بمثال سهل.
هذا متجه ذاتي لـ MA، سميناه psi صفر، وهو مجموع
ket واحد، ket a،
ket A تربيع، وهكذا حتى ket A أس R ناقص واحد، الكل مقسوم على الجذر التربيعي لـ R
ليصبح متجه وحدة. هنا R هي رتبة A.
وسأحجز الحرف
R لرتبة A لبقية الدرس.
فكلما رأيتم R، هذه هي رتبة A لأي
A نتحدث عنه.
القيمة الذاتية المرتبطة
بهذا المتجه الذاتي هي واحد.
ويمكننا التحقق من ذلك
بتطبيق MA على هذا المتجه لنرى ما نحصل عليه.
MA تضرب في A، فنحتاج
فقط لزيادة كل من الأسس
بواحد وهذا ما نحصل عليه.
لكن رتبة A هي R، فـ A أس R يساوي واحد.
ويمكننا إجراء هذا الاستبدال.
لكن هذا نفس المتجه
الذي بدأنا به. كل ما فعلناه هو
خلط الـ kets لكننا نأخذ المجموع فهذا
لا يغير شيئاً.
فـ MA ضرب psi صفر يساوي psi صفر.
فهو متجه ذاتي لـ
MA بقيمة ذاتية واحد.
هذا مثال بسيط جداً
لمتجه ذاتي ولتحديد المزيد منها، لنتذكر نفس الترميز الذي كان لدينا سابقاً في الدرس.
omega R هو العدد
المركب على دائرة الوحدة الذي نحصل عليه بأخذ e أس
اثنين ضرب pi ضرب I
مقسوم على R. المرة السابقة كان لدينا N بدلاً من R، لكنه يعمل بنفس
الطريقة لـ R بدل N.
نحتاج هذا العدد لأنه
سيظهر في المتجهات الذاتية الأخرى
لـ MA التي سنحددها.
والآن بعد تذكر ذلك الترميز، يمكننا ملاحظة أن هذا
المتجه المسمى psi واحد هو أيضاً متجه ذاتي لـ MA.
هو مشابه لـ psi صفر، لدينا نفس الـ kets بالضبط ونجمعها و
نقسم على الجذر التربيعي لـ R.
لكن هذه المرة لدينا أطوار مختلفة تضرب كل ket.
omega R أس سالب واحد لـ A، omega R أس سالب اثنين لـ A تربيع، وهكذا حتى omega R أس
سالب R ناقص واحد
لـ A أس R ناقص واحد. فقوة omega R
هي دائماً سالب واحد ضرب أي قوة لـ A
تظهر داخل الـ ket.
لن أمر عليه بالتفصيل، لكنه موضح على الشاشة في حال أردتم إعادة مشاهدة الفيديو والتوقيف عند الحاجة.
لكن إذا قمنا بالضرب وبسطنا مرة أخرى باستخدام حقيقة أن A أس R يساوي واحد
وكذلك الحقيقة المهمة جداً أن omega أس R يساوي واحد، ما سنجده هو أنه
مرة أخرى لدينا متجه ذاتي لـ MA.
هذه المرة عند التبسيط، سنحتاج لاستخراج عامل omega R لنرى أنه فعلاً متجه ذاتي
وأن omega R تمثل القيمة الذاتية المرتبطة بهذا المتجه الذاتي.
هذا هو الزوج الثاني من
المتجه الذاتي والقيمة الذاتية لـ MA.
يمكننا تحديد متجهات ذاتية إضافية باستخدام نفس المنطق بالضبط، وفي الحقيقة، إذا استبدلنا ببساطة omega R
بـ omega R أس J لكل J بين صفر وR ناقص واحد، سنحصل دائماً على متجه ذاتي،
والقيمة الذاتية المرتبطة ستكون omega R أس J.
فهذا يشمل فعلاً
psi صفر وpsi واحد، اللذين رأيناهما سابقاً
وكذلك R ناقص اثنين من أزواج المتجه الذاتي والقيمة الذاتية الأخرى.
جميعها تعمل بنفس الطريقة أساساً، وللتحقق منها، نحتاج فقط لمعرفة أن A أس R يساوي واحد
وكذلك omega R أس
R يساوي واحد.
هناك متجهات ذاتية أخرى لـ MA مثل ket صفر مثلاً، لكنها لن تكون مفيدة لنا ولا نحتاج للقلق بشأنها.
نحتاج فقط للقلق بشأن psi صفر حتى psi R ناقص واحد.
لنركز على psi واحد للحظة، فقط لنحاول فهم لماذا نهتم بهذه المتجهات الذاتية
وما يمكنها إخبارنا
عن الرتبة R، وهي ما نحاول إيجاده.
بافتراض أننا أُعطينا
المتجه الذاتي psi واحد، يمكننا محاولة تعلم
R بالطريقة التالية.
أولاً، نجري تقدير
الطور على هذا المتجه الذاتي باستخدام دارة كمية
تنفذ العملية MA.
ما نحصل عليه هو تقريب لـ theta، وهي واحد على R في هذه الحالة.
وثانياً لأننا نبحث عن R ولدينا
تقريب لواحد على R، الشيء الطبيعي هو
حساب المقلوب
وتقريبه لأقرب
عدد صحيح. يجب التقريب هكذا
لأن R يجب أن يكون عدداً صحيحاً.
لكن ليس لدينا واحد على R بالضبط، لدينا فقط تقريب له.
لكن إذا كان التقريب جيداً بما يكفي، سنحصل على R عند التقريب،
وهذا ما نبحث عنه.
والآن السؤال هو كم من الدقة نحتاج لتحديد R بشكل صحيح عن طريق حساب المقلوب والتقريب؟
أو بعبارة أخرى، ما مدى دقة
تقريبنا المطلوبة لجعل كل هذا يعمل؟
حسناً، يتبين أننا نحتاج فعلاً تقريباً دقيقاً جداً.
مثلاً، لا يمكننا
أن نخلط بين واحد على R وواحد على R زائد واحد، أو واحد على R ناقص واحد مثلاً.
في هذين الكسرين، واحد على R زائد واحد و
واحد على R ناقص واحد قريبان جداً من واحد
على R عندما يكون R كبيراً.
لكن رغم أننا نحتاج
تقريباً دقيقاً جداً، لا نحتاج تقريباً
دقيقاً بشكل سخيف، ويمكن إثبات أنه
إذا كان تقريبنا
يحقق المتراجحة الموجودة
هنا على الشاشة، فإن التقريب لأقرب عدد صحيح
سيعطينا الإجابة الصحيحة.
لن أحاول شرح ذلك في هذا الفيديو، لكنه موضح في المادة
المكتوبة للدرس في حال كنتم مهتمين بالتفاصيل.
وإذا كانت تلك هي الدقة
التي نسعى إليها، فيكفي استخدام
عدد من qubits التحكم في إجراء تقدير الطور
يساوي اثنين ضرب
طول N زائد واحد.
حيث كما كان في الدروس السابقة، طول N هو عدد البتات التي نحتاجها للتعبير عن N بالنظام الثنائي.
بالمناسبة، إذا اكتفينا
بالحصول على أفضل تقريب باحتمال 40% على الأقل ولم نحاول زيادة
ثقتنا
كما وصفت سابقاً، فلا نحتاج فعلاً لزائد واحد.
لكن في كل الأحوال، لدينا أن عدد
qubits التحكم المطلوب خطي في طول N
مكتوبة كسلسلة ثنائية.
رأينا أنه إذا كان لدينا
المتجه الذاتي psi واحد، يمكننا استخدام تقدير الطور لإيجاد R، بشرط استخدام دقة كافية.
للأسف ليس من السهل الحصول على هذا المتجه الذاتي.
فلنطرح سؤالاً مختلفاً.
لنفترض أنه ليس لدينا psi واحد، بل لدينا psi J
لاختيار عشوائي لـ J.
هل لا يزال بإمكاننا معرفة R؟ أو على الأقل هل يمكننا
معرفة شيء عن R؟
والجواب هو نعم، يمكننا معرفة شيء
عن R، على الأقل في المتوسط.
ما يمكننا فعله هو محاولة
معرفة J على R باستخدام طريقة مشابهة جداً
للتي رأيناها للتو،
لكن مع فرق جوهري.
أولاً، سنفعل نفس
الشيء بالضبط الذي فعلناه سابقاً، وهو تشغيل إجراء
تقدير الطور على المتجه الذاتي psi J.
وما سنحصل عليه هو
تقريب لـ J على R، بدلاً من واحد على R،
وهو ما كان لدينا سابقاً.
لكن الآن لدينا مشكلة صغيرة، لأن حساب
المقلوب لن يعطينا R، بل سيعطينا R على J.
وبالمناسبة، لا نفترض
أننا نعرف ما هي J، نحن ببساطة أُعطينا psi J لـ J عشوائية،
ولم يُخبرنا ما هي J. فماذا يمكننا أن نفعل؟
حسناً، يتبين أن هناك خوارزمية
كلاسيكية معروفة يمكنها مساعدتنا، تُسمى
خوارزمية الكسور المستمرة.
وما تستطيع هذه الخوارزمية فعله هو أخذ تقريبنا
Y على اثنين أس M وإخبارنا أي كسر U على V،
مكتوب بأبسط صورة، وحيث U وV كلاهما
عددان صحيحان أصغر من N هو الأقرب لتقريبنا.
إنها خوارزمية رائعة حقاً، وإذا كنتم مهتمين بها، يجب عليكم بالتأكيد الاطلاع عليها.
هي مرتبطة ارتباطاً وثيقاً بخوارزمية Euclid لحساب
القاسم المشترك الأكبر في الحقيقة.
لكن لن أقول المزيد
عنها في هذا الفيديو.
النقطة من هذا هي أنه إذا كان لدينا تقريب
جيد لكسر ما بسطه و
مقامه ليسا كبيرين جداً،
تستطيع الخوارزمية استرداد الكسر، وهذا ما نفعله هنا.
والآن تبقى لدينا نفس
السؤال بالضبط كما سابقاً، وهو كم من الدقة نحتاج؟
ويتبين أن نفس
الحد بالضبط الذي كان لدينا سابقاً يعمل في هذه الحالة.
واختيار M بنفس الطريقة
بالضبط كما سابقاً يعمل هنا أيضاً.
الآن هذا ليس بالضرورة
سيخبرنا بـ R.
ما سنتعلمه إذا استخدمنا
دقة كافية، هو J على R، لكن ذلك سيكون
كسراً في أبسط صورة.
فقد نكون غير محظوظين بمعنى أن هذا الاختيار العشوائي لـ J قد يكون له عوامل مشتركة مع R،
وستكون مخفية عنا. في أسوأ الحالات مثلاً، يمكن أن نحصل على J يساوي صفر ولن نتعلم شيئاً على الإطلاق.
لكن هذه حرفياً الحالة الوحيدة
التي لا نتعلم فيها شيئاً.
بشكل عام، سنحصل على الأقل
على عامل غير تافه لـ R، وإذا استطعنا سحب عينات عشوائية
والحصول على psi J لاختيارات مختلفة لـ J، يمكننا فعلاً استرداد
R باحتمال عالٍ عن طريق حساب المضاعف المشترك الأصغر
لجميع المقامات
التي نلاحظها. وهذا في الحقيقة
لا يتطلب عينات كثيرة على الإطلاق.
الخلاصة هي أن بعض اختيارات J ستخفي عوامل R، لكن الاختيارات العشوائية لـ J
لن تتمكن من إخفاء
عوامل R لوقت طويل.
هذه هي الفكرة إذن. يبقى النظر في التنفيذ وبالتحديد معرفة
كم يكلف.
جوهر الفكرة، لحساب رتبة
عنصر معين A في ZN نجمة هو تطبيق إجراء تقدير الطور
على العملية MA.
لنكتشف ما هي
تكلفة فعل ذلك كدالة في طول N الكبيرة، التي سأرمز لها بـ n الصغيرة.
هذه دارة لتقدير الطور. سنحتاج n الصغيرة من الـ qubits في الجزء السفلي من الدارة
لترميز عناصر ZN بالنظام الثنائي. فلدينا N من qubits التحكم في الأعلى وn الصغيرة من الـ qubits في الأسفل،
وهو أمر جيد لأنه يتوافق مع الأسماء التي
استخدمناها سابقاً في الدرس.
لحساب عدد
الـ gates المطلوبة للدارة بأكملها، لنركز أولاً على تكلفة العمليات الأحادية المتحكم بها.
إذا استخدمنا التقنيات
من الدرس السابق، الدرس السادس، يمكننا تنفيذ MA باستخدام O كبيرة من n الصغيرة تربيع gate
باستخدام خوارزميات كلاسيكية فعالة للحساب بالقياس N.
سأتخطى التفاصيل في هذا الفيديو، لكن مثل عدة
أشياء أخرى تحدثت عنها، يمكنكم قراءة المزيد عنها في المادة المكتوبة للدرس.
لكن لا يكفي
تنفيذ MA فقط.
نحتاج أيضاً لتنفيذ MA تربيع، MA أس أربعة، أس
ثمانية، وهكذا
حتى MA أس قوة أسية في M.
ونعلم أننا سنحتاج لأخذ M ليكون خطياً في n الصغيرة
للحصول على دقة كافية.
هذا مصدر قلق كبير،
وقد أثرته سابقاً.
إذا كنا سننفذ قوى
MA بتكرار MA ببساطة، سنكون في مشكلة لأن كل هذه التكرارات لـ MA
ستكلف تكلفة أسية.
لحسن الحظ، يمكننا استخدام حيلة لتجنب هذا الانفجار في التكلفة.
ما يمكننا فعله هو كالتالي، لكل قوة K نحتاجها.
أولاً، نحسب A أس
K، بالقياس N.
هذه مسألة الرفع الأسي بالقياس التي ذكرتها في الدرس السادس.
ويمكن حلها بكفاءة. وهذا شيء يمكننا فعله بحاسوب كلاسيكي.
هذا الحساب لا يحتاج
لأن يُنفذ بدارة كمية على الإطلاق.
فلنسمِّ النتيجة B.
فـ B عنصر من ZN نجمة.
وثانياً، بدلاً من MA أس K، نستخدم ببساطة دارة لـ MB.
وهذا كل شيء. B هو مجرد عنصر من ZN نجمة، فتكلفة تنفيذ MB
هي O كبيرة من n الصغيرة تربيع.
باختصار، ما نفعله هو الرفع الأسي في ZN بدلاً من الرفع الأسي
لدارة كمية.
لكن العملية الفعلية التي
نحصل عليها هي نفسها في كلتا الحالتين. هي مجرد الضرب في A، K مرة.
هذا أشبه بمعجزة في الحقيقة. ولم نكن لنتمكن من
حل مسألة إيجاد الرتبة أو تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة بكفاءة
بحاسوب كمي
لولا هذا.
والآن بعد أن عرفنا أن كل عملية
أحادية متحكم بها، بما في ذلك القوى، يمكن تنفيذها
بتكلفة O كبيرة من n تربيع، يمكننا حساب العدد الإجمالي
للـ gates المطلوبة.
لدينا N من gates Hadamard، ولأن M يساوي
O كبيرة من n الصغيرة، التكلفة هي O كبيرة من n الصغيرة.
لدينا M عملية أحادية متحكم بها كل منها بتكلفة O كبيرة من n تربيع.
فالتكلفة الإجمالية هنا
هي O كبيرة من n مكعب.
وأخيراً، تحويل Fourier الكمي بتكلفة O كبيرة من n تربيع.
فالتكلفة الإجمالية هي O كبيرة من n مكعب.
بالتحديد، نرى أنه حتى مع حيلة
الرفع الأسي بالقياس، تكلفة العمليات
الأحادية المتحكم بها هي المهيمنة.
لكن مع ذلك، التكلفة
متعددة الحدود في n الصغيرة.
هناك أيضاً بعض الحسابات
الكلاسيكية المطلوبة، مثل حساب الرفع الأسي بالقياس وتشغيل خوارزمية
الكسور المستمرة،
لكن تلك الحسابات
أيضاً ذات تكلفة متعددة الحدود. وفي الحقيقة، يمكن إنجازها بـ O كبيرة من n مكعب عملية أيضاً.
يبقى مسألة واحدة فقط، وهي أننا نحتاج للحصول على أحد هذه المتجهات الذاتية.
كيف يمكننا فعل ذلك؟
الحل في الحقيقة بسيط جداً. لا نشغل الدارة
على متجه ذاتي.
نشغلها ببساطة على الحالة واحد، أي الترميز
الثنائي للعدد واحد، الذي نفكر
فيه كعنصر من ZN.
فلنقم بهذا
الاستبدال في المخطط.
السبب في أن هذا يعمل هو بسبب هذه المعادلة هنا.
الحالة ket واحد هي في
الحقيقة تراكب منتظم للمتجهات الذاتية R التي
كنا نتحدث عنها.
وهذا ليس واضحاً على الفور، لكن إذا حسبتم
المجموع، يجب أن تحصلوا على ket واحد.
وإذا شغلنا الدارة على هذه الحالة، المخرج الذي سنحصل عليه
سيكون نفسه تماماً كما لو اخترنا J عشوائياً
وشغلنا الإجراء على
المتجه الذاتي psi J.
مرة أخرى، هذا ليس واضحاً، لكن التحليل يكشف أنه صحيح.
وأخيراً، هذا كل شيء. لدينا خوارزمية كمية
فعالة لإيجاد الرتبة.
يبقى جزء قصير جداً
من الدرس ويتعلق بالعلاقة بين تحليل الأعداد الصحيحة
وإيجاد الرتبة.
ذكرت أنه إذا استطعنا حل مسألة إيجاد الرتبة بكفاءة، فيمكننا أيضاً تحليل
الأعداد الصحيحة بكفاءة.
وأريد أن أعطيكم بإيجاز الفكرة الرئيسية لكيفية عمل ذلك.
إنه كلاسيكي بالكامل. هذا الجزء ليس له علاقة
بالحوسبة الكمية في الحقيقة.
هذه طريقة لإيجاد
عامل غير تافه لعدد صحيح موجب معين N.
وبالمناسبة، هذه الطريقة تعمل فقط عندما يكون N عدداً فردياً، وليس عدداً أولياً
مرفوعاً لقوة.
هاتان الحالتان عندما يكون N
زوجياً أو قوة أولية يمكن التعامل معهما بشكل منفصل.
هناك طرق كلاسيكية فعالة لكشف و
التعامل مع هاتين الحالتين.
هذه الطريقة احتمالية. قد تفشل، لكن
احتمال الفشل سيكون نصف على الأكثر،
ويمكننا ببساطة تشغيلها
عدة مرات بشكل مستقل لتقليل احتمال
الخطأ بسرعة أسية.
أولاً، نختار A بين
اثنين وN ناقص واحد عشوائياً، بشكل منتظم.
ثم نحسب القاسم المشترك الأكبر لـ A وN.
وإذا كان القاسم المشترك
الأكبر أكبر من واحد، فقد كنا محظوظين للغاية.
القاسم المشترك الأكبر سيكون عاملاً لـ N ويمكننا ببساطة إخراجه والتوقف.
وإلا، تستمر الخوارزمية ونعلم الآن أن A في ZN نجمة.
والآن نحسب رتبة A، وهنا نحتاج لحاسوب كمي.
أو ربما لدينا طريقة أخرى
لحساب الرتبة. الخوارزمية لا تهتم
من أين تأتي، لكن الطريقة الوحيدة التي نعرفها
لفعل هذا بكفاءة
هي بحاسوب كمي.
إذا كانت الرتبة R زوجية، فنحسب القاسم المشترك الأكبر لـ
A أس R على اثنين ناقص واحد مع N.
وإذا كان ذلك القاسم المشترك الأكبر أكبر من واحد، فمرة أخرى لدينا عامل لـ N، فنخرجه ونتوقف.
وإلا فالخوارزمية فشلت. وفي تلك الحالة، يمكننا
العودة للبداية واختيار A مختلف
ونأمل بنتيجة أفضل
في المرة القادمة.
وهذا كل شيء. وبالمناسبة، بمجرد أن
نجد عاملاً لـ N، يمكننا التكرار على كل من ذلك العامل
وقسمته على ذلك العامل حتى نحصل على تحليل N إلى عوامله الأولية.
فلماذا يجب أن تعمل هذه الطريقة؟
حسناً، هناك نقطتان رئيسيتان. الأولى هي أنه لأن A أس R متطابق مع واحد بالقياس N،
فإن N يقسم A
أس R ناقص واحد.
هاتان العبارتان
متكافئتان فعلاً. هذا هو تعريف mod N الذي ستجدونه في كتب نظرية الأعداد.
ثانياً، إذا كانت R زوجية، فهذه المعادلة
الموجودة هنا صحيحة.
هذه هي الصيغة المعروفة
لفرق المربعات.
في الحقيقة، المعادلة صحيحة لجميع R، لكننا نحتاج R على اثنين ليكون
عدداً صحيحاً في الخطوة الرابعة.
وإذا جمعنا الحقيقتين معاً، نرى أن كل عامل أولي لـ N يجب أن يقسم أحد التعبيرين
بين القوسين،
لأن هذه هي الطريقة الوحيدة
التي يمكن بها لـ N أن يقسم الجداء.
الآن، يمكن أن يكون كل
عامل أولي لـ N يقسم التعبير الأول
بين القوسين وليس الثاني، لكن بالنسبة لـ A العشوائي،
هذا ليس مرجحاً جداً. وعندما نحسب
القاسم المشترك الأكبر في الخطوة الرابعة، من المرجح أن نحصل على جداء
بعض العوامل الأولية
لـ N، لكن ليس كلها.
لتحليل هذا بدقة
يتطلب بعض نظرية الأعداد، لكنها نظرية أعداد أساسية جداً.
فإذا وجدتم نظرية
الأعداد مثيرة للاهتمام وأردتم تعلم المزيد عنها، حاولوا العمل من خلال هذا التحليل.
العمل من خلال أشياء كهذه هو طريقة ممتازة لتعلم المزيد، لكنني سأترك ذلك لكم.
وهذه نهاية الدرس. في هذا الدرس، غطينا
مسألة تقدير الطور، كيف يمكننا حلها بكفاءة
على حاسوب كمي،
وكيف يمكننا تطبيق الحل للحصول على خوارزمية كمية
بتكلفة متعددة الحدود لتحليل الأعداد الصحيحة.
آمل أن تنضموا إليّ في الدرس القادم، وهو عن خوارزمية
Grover للبحث الكمي.
وداعاً حتى ذلك الحين.